Trader Joe's
tuna salad with jerk style plantain
chips is
is
uh you you will Ascend to God it's
euphoric it is so good when would you
say
this meal would hit the hardest like
after lunch just middle of the day lunch
uh actually the truly what does it is
you toast pieces of sourdough you got
your eyes closed that's how much you
like this you toast yes I am yeah you
toast a couple pieces of sourdough bread
you put on some great proponent on that
uh that sourdough bread glob on the damn
tuna salad that's right some sliced
pieces of avocado you get a a dill spear
dill pickle spear on the side and you
have the plantain chips all there uh to
munch on on the side and a peppercini
that sounds delicious the pepperoncinis
got just enough Tang just enough bite
you let the liquid go under the sandwich
oh it's so good yeah sounds like it it's
so delicious I believe heartburn
you wanna know something what I'm
allergic to Seafood
full on so I'll never have that
experience you poor guy how did you find
out
um
eating it as a child and feeling my
throat closing wow yeah do you remember
what what was it fish yeah
salmon
God damn
but so you've never had sushi nope
I'm socially
I don't know how you describe this
uh that's I think that's what makes me a
robot sometimes is that you haven't had
sushi yeah a little bit like you ever
going out with people like Oh sushi oh
my God it's gonna be so good yeah oh
hell yeah I [__] love this place yeah
I go there with people and I go
looks like a good time yeah
I'm gonna eat chicken you should try it
again
um I'm certain I've tried things really
yeah
I mean it's not it's not like if I sniff
it I'ma die sure so I could probably eat
one roll and then be like oh that's
[__] awesome yeah but I wonder like
if you could have scallops or clams
is it just the fact that it comes from
the sea yeah I could have scallops and
clams if you never want me to podcast
again that would be the because it would
kill you potentially oh Jesus yeah
man but it would take a decent amount
honestly yeah like chocolate for a dog
yeah yeah I could probably eat like half
a fish and then it's anaphylactic you
poor guy you can't experience the joys
of Branzino no oh dude how was it
weren't you just in New York yeah how
was it man it's fantastic I was there
for a couple days no fish though no fish
no fish for me yeah you were there yes
sir where'd you perform
the town hall theater
it was awesome is it in the city it is
it's actually like Midtown do you stick
around after your shows to meet people
um tip well we have so much gear on this
run so I just kind of hang and uh I have
so many shows stacked up back to back
that now post show I need like a good
hour to like decompress sure what the
[__] I just did so people kind of hang
you know people wait for me uh we're
doing on this part of the Run we have
the bus so some people hang around the
bus and yeah I'll say what's up yeah
cool people hang out we uh we did our
show at a much much much much much much
smaller venue hey man
hey and it was great uh and it sold out
in just a couple minutes dude congrats
thank you well how big is the room uh a
hundred and twenty thousand thousand a
hundred MSG four nights at MSG it was
120 people at a little spot called
caveat that's awesome and uh we're gonna
do another venue in July called The Bell
House in Brooklyn which is like 350.
that'll be fun and hopefully that sells
out quick because I think the sweet spot
is 250. really
for like just a live podcast for Live
Comedy of of any kind I think 250 is why
not just a thousand
um a couple like the big theaters are
fun too uh definitely it really depends
on like Acoustics design whatever yeah
but
I say 250 is like the sweet spot is
because all the people in the back can
still see your face and uh
which is actually so going back to like
why it takes us forever to break down
after a show it's because I figured out
how to feed live video into a like a
screen behind me because I wanted people
in the back of the theater to be able to
see my face
[Music]
um to be as much like that comedy club
feel as you can get but yeah I think 250
is where it's because then if you're
[__] with the crowd the people can
hear that person they can kind of make
out who that person is yeah and they can
see you animating and everything just
feels like really real time and fun so
what's what's going to be the show is it
live pod didn't know it's well it's just
it's just us we just we yeah we did our
thing we talked we did a little
PowerPoint presentation yeah we brought
one bit I played uh tick tock oh
um and yeah there was surprisingly a lot
to just talk about in Riff on yeah and
at certain points it feels silly it's
like these people are just watching us
to
talk up here but that's what it is and
when you accept that you know you're
fine it's definitely it's definitely fun
I feel you on the The Meta
yeah yeah we did an intro video we paid
a guy on Fiverr to do an intro video
which was great fun and he ended up
doing it for free he was like
I want to this is cool this is such a
far cry from what I normally do I'll
just do it for free and I'm saying all
right that's awesome thank you sir
yeah
um
so did you guys did that and you just
chill for a few days
chilled for a few days I ate a lot of
pizza yeah
I yeah
yeah uh are you okay no I'm fine my
blood is becoming [__] marinara sauce
yeah uh and
yeah I went to my favorite uh there's
this Ukrainian Restaurant that I really
like Domino's no it's not Domino's
everybody knows that's Italian not
Ukrainian saw some friends I smoked
cigarettes
smoked a lot it's okay you like yeah
you're very regretful about your recent
Behavior what are you talking about
there's nothing in my behavior recently
that I regret nothing
I have a story for you afterwards oh boy
okay you'll appreciate it okay
yeah uh anyway should we should we get
some sling dude are you all right yeah
yeah I care about you no I'm fine sir
you want to be you don't want to be
vulnerable well yeah what do you want to
talk about what do you want to talk
about I'm looking at you I don't care
man I drank a pound of coffee so I'm
like I'm On One wow wow
um
well I'm currently uh
[Music]
[Laughter]
no no fine truly oh we believe you well
because it's just funny like doing the
show the live show it's and you've
probably experienced the same thing you
get DMS from people all the time yeah
expressing their gratitude for for what
you put out there and it can take the
form of someone saying you know this I
look forward to this every week or
um this is the only thing on the
internet that I enjoy what the [__] ever
uh and sometimes it's a little more than
that like there was a guy at the show
who just stuck around afterward to say
look I just wanted to say because of
your show I have a relationship with my
brother now I was like whoa and he said
yeah he's into this stuff I wasn't into
it I started listening to your show now
I'm into it and now I have something to
talk about with my brother and we talk
all the time and I was like hot diggity
that's cool
and because of certain episodes either
on here or on our show
where I've
bared my [__] soul to a camera yeah
you forget that there are people on the
other side of that camera yeah and
um seeing some of them in person and
having them express to you face to face
what the what you do
how it's meaningful to them it's a very
special experience yeah it's very
touching it's very life-affirming yeah
and
um
yeah you just the contrast of that with
going through a kind of depressive
moment is uh
is weird
to kind of be like feeling like total
[__] but then for different reasons but
then to have
um
you have to have these people
give you love it's it's really nice yeah
it is it's uh yeah it can save you a bit
is that what you were wondering about
when you asked me if I stick around to
talk to people it kind of yeah I'm just
because it was a lot it was like I mean
we only had like 50 people hanging
around but they all wanted to take a
photo and they all wanted to say hi it
was not a small number true that's a lot
of people dude but it was like it was
overwhelming yeah and I cannot imagine
having the energy for that after every
show ah no I mean I don't I don't think
it really takes energy it's like
it's a pretty positive thing every time
sure yeah
um
uh yeah that's uh it's definitely very
cool it's a it takes you out of your
head I think you know if you're like in
your head and then you walk outside and
there's like human beings like hey man I
really like that [__] you did yeah it's
like ah you know what okay
yeah
um
but so
I uh I'm laughing because I didn't know
how to phrase the following which is I'm
now seeing two therapists
just to compare no uh this this uh my my
current one was like you know you should
maybe think about seeing someone who
really specializes in OCD oh and
I said okay and I went and saw this
woman once and uh we agreed to
to keep going and I'm seeing her again
this week uh but I'm still working with
my other one and I'm just like man my
stats are going to be so my mental
health stats yeah like I'm in uh help me
here with this video game analogy yeah
like what am I doing here uh you're
getting my stats up right yeah yeah
you're you're like you
are basically
adding more points to like a secondary
skill tree yeah XP yeah XP yeah for my
side quests that I that I'm gonna do no
I mean it's like you you already you
know you already maxed out on one now
you're creating like a subclass I'm
maxed out on penis uh what's up uh hey
this guy's got a this guy's got a big
dick that's what he's saying